let's bring in that Quinn Buckner former
NBA player and working for Fox Sports in
Indianapolis the Pacers analyst hey buck
good to talk to you again how would you
sum up what happened yesterday between
the Pacers and the Cavs well with what
the Pacers I the Pacers have been
playing like this all year and they're
very confident but they know that
they're playing against two LeBron James
who's you know you can make the argument
I make it I'll make it you don't have to
make it the best player in the game and
they knew going in there that it was
going to be tough to get any kind of
wind so I thought they played with a
with a greater enthusiasm but I also
think that as LeBron is trying to figure
this team out what he's looking at our
some guys on his team with with Clarkson
with hood Nance I thought they played up
to the moment the other guys that looked
to me a bit a little bit shell-shocked
tonight and since they haven't been
together for a while you could see that
they work as quite in sync as I think
the Pacers are because this lineup has
been the same for predominantly the year
all the Depot doesn't seem afraid and I
what surprised me is you know the Cavs
have no interior defense in and if
that's the case then Oladipo I would
just say I just put the ball in his
hands and say go in whatever's there
take whatever you want to take because I
don't think Cleveland can do anything
unless they bring in Tristan Thompson so
what's what's Cleveland do to counteract
what happened in Game one well I expect
him to come out and first of all play
with a great deal more energy than they
did yesterday I said they first of all
you get basically embarrassed at home in
a playoff game so I think they'll do
that and I think defensively is where
you probably see a lot more energy
obviously all the Depot is the person
you know that's the go-to guy for the
Pacers and I wouldn't be surprised to
see them just try to get the ball out of
his hands the way the Pacers have played
though they're what Victor is really
good at is sharing it's not like he has
to make the big play he just at the
moments there he'll make it and but I
think he'll share it with his teammates
and you got guys Madonna did can shoot
the ball Myles played well yesterday
what I thought was really huge the two
guards Cory Joseph Carlos and play good
and Lance give some energy but these
guys have been planted again this is not
like they're out of character this is
just the way they played all year long
and so I wasn't surprised to see them
play the way they did I was a little
more so
that Cleveland didn't have the kind of
resistance that I thought they would
have that but that's what I expect to be
very different on Wednesday I know
Victor Oladipo said that he was
motivated a little bit by what dan
Gilbert the Cavs owner said at the time
when Paul George was dealt to Oklahoma
City and they got sabonis and you've got
Victor and and that they should have
gotten more you know buck everybody
around the league said the same thing it
wasn't like you know it was just Dan
Gilbert I I'm sure I'm sure people in
Indiana probably thought wait that's all
we got for Paul George well I think
there was that sentiment was pervasive
you're absolutely right it was the
pervasive sentiment I the nature of the
media is yeah they took that and ran
with it for today that's that's the
nature of that beast Victor did it he
acknowledged it first of all and once
you acknowledge it it gives people
opportunity for that what Victor has
been what he's got to do and what he's
been doing this entire team all of these
guys on this team are trying to prove
something Victor's been traded twice
didn't you know got a shot at Oak
Orlando that didn't work out he goes and
plays with Westbrook which I think those
combinations were really good for him
because in Orlando they tried to play
him at point guard initially and he
really didn't understand the position
and I'm having we're both alumni of
Indiana University and I've watched him
he didn't know what that was he got
better at that then he goes and watch
Russ you watch Russell Westbrook the way
he plays you know he's got a train at a
high level so I think Victor being there
gave him a chance to see hey I thought I
was getting ready but I wasn't ready for
for what this is about and I think
because this year the thing that's I
think the two things you got to have in
this business if you got to be in great
physical shape but mentally you got to
be a lot tougher and I think that's
where he really kind of advanced
now what happens not not unlike any
player and it just don't have to be a
great player but any player you always
should be finding something to keep you
motivated in this game it's just it's a
long season there's a lot of work that's
involved and I think that you know
whether or not people thought that pace
has got enough for Paul George was part
of that then Gilbert happened to say
that but you also remember Dan Gilbert
in the Cleveland Cavs we're trying to
get Paul George as well so I'm sure they
felt like that package was better than
what you could get from Oklahoma City so
I'm sure there's some comedy
that that feeds into that thought
process yeah that's a good point Quinn
Buckner joining us Fox Sports
Indianapolis Pacers analyst a favorite
Larry Bird story I don't tell Larry Bird
stories you tell Michael Jordan Larry is
it such a unique personality I don't
have necessarily stories I'm I just what
I what what challenges means I marvel at
people who think the guys they hit Larry
is one of the smartest pragmatic people
I know and I mean and my mother god rest
her soul was very bright coach Knight is
probably coach Knight and Bill Russell
are probably the two brightest people
that I know Larry is is maybe right
under that in that category and when
people keep talking about him being a
hick Larry understood what he
understands as well as anybody is
personality than people and that's why
he would do his junk talking he pulled
it for airing here on radio because he
understood people who would let that
bother them and what they would do when
it bothers them that's that's the way
Larry that was his gamesmanship so
that's really the only story I can tell
you about Larry I just think he's one of
the brightest guys that I know so that's
my story on Larry what else you want to
know well okay didn't we talk about this
before when you guys played the Chicago
Bulls first round of the playoffs and
you guys went out it might have been you
and Roby and you went out with bird and
the Chicago Bulls cheerleaders bought
you beers figuring that they could get
Larry drunk and then Larry lit him up
and then walked off the floor and walked
by the cheerleaders and said thanks for
the beers but the story is true that is
very typically Larry's okay I knew right
oh he knew what was happening he knew
right away what was happening and again
okay so we talked about motivation for
Larry that's another motivation he could
have that in his mind so when he walked
off the court you know he can let you
know hey you can do whatever you want
doesn't make a difference to me I love
that Larry I love that that he knows
that the cheerleaders are buying him
beers and then
just thanked him for the beers after I
think you guys eliminated the Bulls
you're okay so you don't tell bird
stories do you but you beat you were
best friends with bird and with Michael
Jordan I mean but you don't do you tell
Jordan stories you got a story for me no
I don't have a Jordan stuff I really
Michael
Michael is obviously he's done very well
he's a very bright guy you know that the
personalities are very similar you know
they're both a little bit OCD whether
you believe it or not and you can tell
about and this is necessary sounds
strange to people you can tell them when
you're walking through the houses
everything has a place both of them know
and and I think it speaks to they need
order in order for them to have their
success so that's just the way they're
wired so that means it's about a process
and both of them are very processes
oriented guys and and I think that's why
they've had success not only in the lead
but since they've been out of the league
but I don't I don't really I don't
really tell a lot of stories so I'm not
a storyteller yeah that's probably why
I'm still there friends yeah I was gonna
say yeah you don't speak out of school
when it when it comes to that okay
here's my question buck if I had Larry
Bird at 30 years of age against LeBron
James at 30 years of age both healthy
and bird I think average 30 a game that
year who would you take bird at his peak
LeBron at his peak one season
hard-pressed not to take I'd be
hard-pressed not to take Larry's now
that may be you know there may be some
personal bias there but I'd be
hard-pressed not to take Larry just
because I don't think but you know we're
really splitting hairs here about
players you know you can get into the
everything you're just talking about two
guys that winning is paramount and more
importantly they understand that the
necessity to have their teammates be as
successful as they are they really do
and they both work at it because if they
do that those guys make a bigger
contribution and it's less of a load but
if they have to take the load they take
they're very very similar so that's not
splitting here but hairs but I I'd
probably take Larry Berkeley in the crew
we're talking about this yesterday where
they were talking about
you can't stop James Harden and
it feels I sound like the guy who says
get off my lawn but it feels like he
gets away with an awful lot he's
physical uses that shoulder and you know
he's been known to add a step or two in
traveling but how would you how would
you rank what you see with Hardin with
the Great's of all-time scoring cuz now
Kareem was it you know nobody could
defend Kareem I think that's the one
play in basketball no one could ever
guard Kareem you know if Kareem missed
it's because Kareem missed not because
you were guarding him but as far as guys
that you can't defend where does James
Harden fit in that category I don't know
what how do you get into category but
he's the same way regardless of what he
gets away with part of you gets away
with it because he's just that good and
he understands the nuances or the rules
that well but he can't be guarded I'm
sorry I you know you like I have watched
this for many many years I'm not seeing
anybody with the ball in their hands as
much as he has in his hands even though
it's a different era game to be able to
score the way that will keep scores head
will ory and now what he's done and this
is principally in the last I think two
years when he's done better he's a
better play maker he is a much better
play maker and he got it you know it
takes guys a while to understand you
come in this league and you come in the
league and it's been solely your game
that's pretty much got you here but your
game it's pretty much been offensive
minded about you at some point you start
recognizing it's got to be about the
greater good of the balance of the team
Michael had figured that out you know
from Carolina with the system they have
God rest his soul with Dean Smith and
all of that Michael had to go get 63
points against the Celtics and lose
before he was convinced that it was more
important that he figured out not only
where he needed the score and when he
needed the score but how he got his
teammates involved in the game otherwise
you don't win championships you just no
one can do this by themselves Kareem
couldn't do it by himself at any place
he's been he played with a lot of other
great players and many of them like
Larry and and and the great players are
probably going to be in the Hall of Fame
when it's all said and done as you look
at this era that's just the way it is
and hardness
figure that out if they wouldn't a
championship that will be the reason he
wins the championship his scoring is
important but getting everybody else
involved Clint capela how about him
yesterday then I was about four years
ago was barely doing anything on the
court and now they got him in here you
got a you have to do when you give out
the book report you got to figure out
where's capela so that's all part of it
who's more unguardable Harden Jordan
Kobe anybody else you want to put in
there LeBron they're all they're all in
the same category they really are
they're just different errors but
they're they're all in the same category
but harden harden takes that three Mike
didn't use the three but I just it feels
like inside outside harden is gonna get
free throws he can take you off the
dribble he can shoot the three I don't
know if there's anybody else you know
Kobe could do that too but I don't think
he was as good a three-point shooter so
he is Harden maybe above Jordan no he's
no no I'm gonna do that was his shot
that and harden just is a better
three-point shooter but I if the
three-point shooting had been a bit more
intimate for an intricate part of the
game at that point when Michael was at
his peak he need to figure that out
what he didn't need it what Michael
would do is instead of taking the three
points yeah he'd take the ball and he'd
dunk on you you call him you get a three
point play so it's six one way and half
dozen the other when you look at it
there the net effect was the same and
then became a lot like the three-point
shot that hard makes when he's covered
it becomes a bit debilitating when you
watch those guys go in and make the
plays that they want to make when they
have to be made no that's what great
players do but good to talk to you again
maybe next time you'll have a Jordan
story for us or a bird story Thank You
Quinn that's a Quinn Buckner Fox Sports
Indianapolis for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show at
you
[Music]